folks have had enough and against a
clear backdrop they voted him in and he
is sticking sticking to it um about not
having a central bank that cows to other
countries or that is manipulating the
currency Argentina President elect
Javier mle has strongly reiterated his
commitment to closing a country's
Central Bank emphasizing that it is
non-negotiable matter Argentina is in
the west uh barely with the economy and
things sliding and he's come out he's
basically said listen I'm going to break
the back of inflation I'm going to do
this and he sees the manipulation of the
you know of the central banks all all
throughout the West he's even go so far
to say that in a pinch he would petition
for the US dollar to be the
currency and by the way that's not
unusual there are there are dollar
proxies all around the world